If there is one thing to unite this
world, it is the hatred of small talk.
It doesn't matter if it's a corporate
company event or maybe it's just a
weekend networking. It can be terrible.
It can be downright scary at times. So,
how do you do it? And how do you get
better at it? Well, I got you. Today,
we're talking all about how to never
struggle with small talk. Small talk,
it's gross. So, how are we going to fix
that? Let me give you some hints. Number
one, instead of just asking, "How's
work? How's home?" Those kind of
questions just fall flat. They do
nothing for you. They don't move the
conversation at all. Instead, we're
going to switch it to ask questions that
are actionoriented. That means questions
about the doing. So, instead of how's
work, how's home, how are you, you're
going to be asking questions like, "What
did y'all do this weekend? What do you
have coming up?" getting things that
they're excited about. What are you
excited about today or tomorrow or this
week? When you say, "What are you doing
or going?" Those are actionoriented
things and they're going to help push
the conversation forward. Number two,
now what matters is how you do it. If
you notice, I didn't say um do you have
anything going on this weekend? Because
how are you going to respond to that?
You're going to respond to that as
either a yes or a no. That's it. When
you ask questions typically that are did
or did you have fun today? Did you have
a good day? When you ask your kid when
you pick them up from school, did you
have a good day? You're really only
giving them a few options to say yes or
no. When you ask questions that are
closed, that's what they're called,
closedended questions. They only leave
you hardly anywhere to go. It's just a
yes or no question. Do you go to the
store? Yes or no. Instead, you're going
to be opening it up with asking and
beginning the phrase or question with
what. What you see, I always say, what
did y'all do this weekend or did instead
of did you have fun this weekend, you
hear the difference between what did you
do for fun this weekend versus did you
have fun this weekend? One invites you
to open up. The other closes it down and
ends the discussion. So, anytime that
you can, I want you to ask an open-ended
question. You do that by beginning with
what or how or when because it gets them
to continue to talk. That's what you're
after. And also number three, if you
find that you just don't have that much
to talk about or it starts to go
downhill and you finding that each of
your responses are getting shorter and
shorter, that's okay. There's nothing
wrong with that. People feel like there
has to be a certain amount of time for
it to count as small talk. No. If if you
just say hello to the person and you
engage maybe in one little back and
forth, that's small talk. You've done
it. Congratulations. There's no medal.
There's no reward. There's nobody
counting and timing you to see how long
you've been talking. Just if the
conversation comes to a natural end,
then just say, "Hey, great to talk to
you." And politely end the conversation.
Don't feel like you have to keep pushing
and pushing to have some green check
flag to say, "I have accomplished small
talk." It's a lot less than you think to
make that happen. All right. Now, on top
of making sure your questions are
actionoriented, asking about the going,
the doing, what they're excited about,
what's up ahead, what's going on in the
future, on top of making sure that
you're asking open-ended questions that
are leaving lots of space and begin with
with what, how, and when, and not, did,
that's going to close things off. On top
of that, there is a formula that I'm
going to teach you real quick, and it
has always worked for me, and I know it
can work for you, too. This is how it
goes. Number one, you just pick a topic,
any topic, to talk to this person about.
So, let's say it's as boring as the
weather. You could say, "And this
weather was crazy. This weather can't
make up its mind today." They're gonna
come up with something. They're going to
say, "Yeah, oh, I know. Yeah, right.
It's crazy." They're going to
acknowledge you in some way. Perfect.
You have now set the stage for you to
give options. I like to think of it as a
poll. Um, and a p meaning you're going
to say, for example, in in this example,
you can say, so you are you a fall
person or you a winter person? You like
it hot or you you like it cold? Or maybe
it can be summer or winter. Are you you
a fan of summer or do you like it cold?
Would you rather be too hot or too cold?
You're giving them options. That's the
key. options because options give us
something to talk about rather than just
forcing it down one shoot and hoping
that it works. So if I were to say, you
know, are you you like the beach in
summer or are you more like you like the
mountains and the the snow? They're
going to give you one. They're going to
give you one option. They're not going
to just leave you hanging. Or they might
just say, you know what, I really like
spring. Spring's kind of my thing. It
reminds me of blah blah blah. Well, then
you get to interact and say, "Well, I I
totally hear you. Well, I happen to be a
fall person because it makes me think of
football and Thanksgiving and uh here in
America, we have Thanksgiving in
November." And so, that's what I really
like. And then you get to kind of
interact with them and say, "What what
about you?" And now you're getting to
get to know them on just a little bit
deeper level. Because here's here's the
trick on on this formula is why it works
for me at least is that when you share
something that is more personal about
you
99% of the time it then opens it up for
the other person to share something a
little bit more personal about them
because they feel like oh well you've
shared something and now I'm going to
share something. It's it's very um it
creates kind of this mutual contract
that's hidden in a way that if I share a
little bit about me and what's personal
to me and what I like, you're then going
to feel a little bit more comfortable
sharing more personal things about you.
And that's what you're curating in that
experience. You can take it wherever you
want to go. But that's that's the
formula. It's that simple. Pick a topic,
create options for them. uh maybe you
create two options at least two maybe
three or four and then you share
something as to which one is your
favorite and then ask them what about
you even the question what about you
continues to open things up in the
dialogue and it it never can really go
wrong that way I mean they call this
small talk not big talk it's just
something short compact that you left
that oh okay I learned a little bit more
about this person and it's something
that you can knock out really in just an
elevator ride it's very quick very easy
let's say you're coming off uh into the
elevator straight from some rain or
whatever. You can easily just open it up
talking about really the weather, the
news, whatever you want. Try that. And
because this episode is about small
talk, I'm going to keep this episode
small. So, let's go uh ahead and get
into my favorite part of the podcast,
and that's where I get to read a
question from a follower. Those that are
part of my newsletter are able to ask me
questions uh by email, and I'm able to
answer them. So, if you're not part of
the newsletter, you can sign up. The
show notes are um or the link for it is
down there in the show notes. All right,
this one I have picked one out. This is
Let me pull it up. This is Linda and she
lives in Leach, Texas. Linda from Lebec.
I think there's a country song in there
somewhere. I went to law school in
Lebec. So, I'm very familiar with it.
Linda says, "Jefferson, I need some
advice. Thank you so much for your
clips." You're very welcome, Linda. I am
I work at a well I'm not gonna say where
she works but I have networking events
and I tend to absolutely clam up where I
stand in the corner and I'm not sure how
to approach anyone or to get to a point
where I feel comfortable talking to
anyone. Do you have any advice? Linda,
I'm I'm sorry you're having trouble with
that. And that's that's absolutely okay.
absolutely okay because what makes you
special is what makes you you. So just
because you're not going around talking
to every single person that is in the
room, Linda, does not make you any less
special or important or of less value.
You find that people can talk a lot and
say nothing at all. All right? So a lot
of the times these networking events are
really just more of a social dance in a
way of just finding who's comfortable
with who and who's friends and who's
not. So, I don't I don't want you to
overthink it, but I know that's not all
that helpful. So, Linda, I'm going to
say some things that I'm going to try to
say some things that are. So, when
somebody is talking with you, one thing
that you can do that I like to do is I
will um it's it becomes subconscious.
But if you want to find that you're more
engaged with people and get kind of
curious with people, uh, physically, one
thing that you can work on is I like to
slowly kind you just kind of your
head a little bit to the side. That
makes it look like you're much more
interested in what they have to say
rather than just like, I just want to
talk to you. So, it's you don't want to
have crazy eyes. You don't want to have
it to where you feel like you're in
front of their face. You're just kind of
at a distance where your shoulders are
relaxed. You feel relaxed. It helps me
uh if you're holding something,
especially these networking events,
everybody kind of expects you to have
something in your hand. It does not have
to be a drink. It can be a snack. It
could be any kind of refreshment that
they have, but it it keeps your hands
busy. And that's that's why I'm saying
it because it keeps your hands from
having to like fiddle with themselves or
maybe you don't know what to do with
them. So, you kind of cross them. When
you hold something, it keeps your stance
open. And what I'm going to encourage
you to do on top of that is to just
barely slide your head to the the side,
either side. It doesn't matter, the left
or the right, but it it gives this
posture of wanting to kind of be
curious. And when you smile and you're
asking questions and they start to
respond, if you can just move your head
just a little bit to the side, it's
going to open them up as if, hey, you're
being a little bit more curious about
them and have more conversation. Another
thing that's going to help, Linda, is
understanding that don't go into these
events thinking you have to talk to
every single person. Like there's a win
and a loss kind of thing. There's
something to win and lose. That's not
it. If you can just go in with the idea
of just talking to one person. Yeah,
it's that basic. Just one person and
having a good conversation with them. I
would rather trade
20 little small talks that mean nothing
at all versus one awesome conversation
with somebody that I want to talk to
every time. I'll trade that every single
time. So, when you're going into these
types of of scenarios, Linda, just it's
going to help you if you already know
who's going to be there and you make
sure that you go talk to that person. If
it's a friend, awesome. That's great.
The biggest thing is that people just
see you around. they see that you're
having a good time. But if you're closed
off in a corner, even if you're talking
to somebody and you just have um you you
have a closed off posture, your arms are
closed, your your shoulders are hunched,
and you're you're kind of turned off to
the group, they're going to find that a
little bit more. It's it's going to
signal at least that you're not wanting
to talk to anybody. Maybe you don't, but
you asked the question, how can we how
can you get better at that? keep a much
more open stance and and go in trying to
think of just one or two people that you
want to make eye contact with in
conversation with. It doesn't mean you
have to plan out these conversations
ahead of time. You certainly can. And
what I would encourage you to do is take
some of the things that I said at the
beginning of this episode
of asking go up to somebody say hi. I
assume either it doesn't matter if you
know them or not. And you can ask them
the question of what what was something
exciting happened in your week? What's
what's h um what's exciting in your life
right now? See how that's just one
question right there. What's exciting in
your life right now? Easy. And you let
them talk and then once they share it,
you share something that's going on and
exciting in your in your life. You can't
just ask a question and then expect not
to have any kind of answer of your own.
So, it's that kind of that back and
forth, that mutual contract that I
talked about, uh, Linda, that's going to
make sure that you are keeping the ball
rolling in the air. And it it is much
easier for you to end the conversation.
This would be point three for you. If
you feel that the conversation is
starting to run low, get out fast. Say,
"Hey, it's it's been great to talk to
you. I'm going to go grab something to
to eat or drink, whatever it is. I'm
going to run to go see whatever it
doesn't matter. It the biggest thing is
if you can end the conversation on a
high note rather than forcing each other
to talk when you really are kind of done
talking to each other and then leave the
conversation well now you kind of
drained each other. So if you can try to
leave the conversation on a high note.
So if they responded to your what's you
know most exciting in your world today
and they give you an awesome answer you
say oh that's fabulous ask maybe another
question about it go oh that's fantastic
and if they don't ask anything of you
typically they should I mean that's they
should but if they don't that's cool we
just say well that's awesome well I'm
I'm super proud of you that sounds
really exciting that's great to talk
with you and then you leave and now
you've left on a high note now Linda
you've made a good impression because
all you do is talk about them and
they're going to they're really going to
like that. So, uh, Linda, those are just
some quick takeaways, but at the end of
the day, you just do what makes you
special. All right? You you do what
makes you you, and if it makes you
uncomfortable, don't do it. You stick
with what feels good in in your lane and
uh what resonates and feels right to
you. You don't like them, and you
definitely don't want them. But
sometimes, no matter what you say, you
find yourself getting sucked into them
anyway. But with what I'm about to show
you today, you're going to handle them
like a pro. Today's episode is all about
how to handle unwanted conversations. If
you want to avoid an unwanted
conversation, number one, don't fight
them because the more that you do, the
more you're going to find yourself in
one. Instead, just let it go by. You do
that by making yourself sound well
disinteresting. This is what I mean.
When somebody's pushing an opinion onto
you, any controversial topic, whether
it's religion, politics, whatever,
they're trying to push something on to
you and you say, "Yeah, I don't know."
Simple as that. Yeah, I don't know. Or,
you know, I'm not sure. Yeah, I'm not
sure about that. You're finding ways to
communicate to them of if you're looking
for a fight, you're not going to find
one here. Number two, this one is the
easiest, but it's the most critical. You
are making them feel heard. It's just
simply acknowledging their point, and
it's very simple to do. This is what it
sounds like. I agree that's an issue.
Period. Somebody's wanting to get all
worked up and they're telling something
to you. All you need to respond is,
yeah, I'm I agree that's an issue. I
agree that's an issue. You're not saying
whether you agree with it or disagree
with it. If anything, they just feel
acknowledged and heard and they say to
themselves, "Oh, okay. They understood
and heard what I said." And number
three, if you need to be a little bit
more direct, you need to tell them that
you're not interested in this
conversation. If they're not getting the
point, here's the way I suggest to do
that. You say, "I typically avoid this
topic." The key word is typically. Yeah,
I typically avoid this topic or I
typically um try not to talk about X, Y,
and Z. The key here is when you say
typically, you're communicating if I've
had this conversation before, it's not
really stimulating to me anymore. So, I
just avoid this topic altogether. You're
not saying that they're wrong. You're
not giving them a fight. You're not
giving them anything for them to bear
their teeth on. You're just simp simply
saying, "I tend to avoid this. I
typically don't do this." And I'm going
to give you a disclaimer on this
episode, particularly when it comes to
political topics. I'm all in favor of
educating yourself and making sure that
you know about the issues out there. I
think you should absolutely exercise
your right to vote. No questions asked.
That's a different question on whether
or not somebody is allowed to force
their opinion onto you and say whether
they're right or wrong or if you're
supposed to push your opinion back and
always have these discussions where you
know it's just beating your head against
a wall. If this person is open-minded
and it's a discussion that you enjoy
having and people have political
discussions all the time and there's no
issues. But other people it's not so
much about change. They don't care about
the change, they care about the
competition. It's like a sport to them.
It's like arguing over their favorite
sports team, who's going to win, who's
going to lose daytoday.
The ultimate consequence of the
discussion, who wins, makes no bearing,
no change on their life. It's just
something that they feel like a team on.
So, they want to have this discussion uh
of intellect to intellect or just issue
to issue and they just want to talk it
out. All kinds of different reasons why
these kind of topics should or may come
up in your life. The key is how do you
balance them? The reason why I have
number one be to pass it by is because
it's that idea of don't attend every
argument you're invited to. Just because
somebody pushes their opinion on to you
to talk about any controversial topic
does not mean that it's an invitation
for you to
mandatorily give your opinion right back
whenever you decide, you know what, I
want to push against you. Actually, I
don't agree with that. You can disagree
all you want. Just know you're walking
right into the conversation. It's no
longer an unwanted conversation. It is a
desired conversation now that you're
giving your opinion. If you want to
avoid these, then you need to just let
them pass by. I say disinterested or be
disinteresting because in many ways,
you're taking all the oxygen out of the
room and their fire can't burn. They
have nothing to get upset about because
you're not giving them anything to jump
on to. You're finding ways to say, you
know what, I don't know about that. You
know what? That's a good question. I'm
really not sure. I'm not sure. It's not
that you're that you don't have your own
opinion. It's not that you're
uneducated. It's just you're not in a
mood to say, "I don't want to get into
this conversation right now." And
there's nothing wrong with that. When it
comes to agreeing with him, understand
nobody can make you agree to something
you don't want to agree to. Nobody can
force you to say something you don't
want to say. But it's critical that
these kind of people when they're
pushing these unwanted conversations
just feel heard. Often if they just feel
acknowledged in some way, they're going
to go away. Not only have you made
yourself disinteresting, they know
they're not going to get anywhere with
this. They know that you're not going to
give them that fight and that excitement
that they're looking for. They just want
to feel acknowledged. So, when you can
say things like we mentioned in number
two of, I agree, that's an issue. I hear
you. Simple as that. I hear you. I agree
that's an issue. I agree.
>> That's all you have to say. Even if you
disagree with them, you're just making
them feel heard. But if they continue to
push and press uh on you to make you
feel uncomfortable in some certain way,
don't hesitate for one second to say I
prefer or I typically you're talking
about what you do in the past. I prefer
not to talk about X, Y, and Z. I I
typically try to avoid topics about blah
blah blah. You can make it even
situational. Uh I I typically avoid
topic X at dinner or at home or at work.
You make it situational where you are in
your environment. Simple as that. And if
they continue to press the button, it's
absolutely okay to say, "I'm not going
there." Period. I'm not going there.
You're saying, "I'm not going into this
conversation. I've given you plenty of
leadups. I've given you signs that I'm
not interested in this." That that means
I have to be explicit with you. I'm not
interested in this conversation. I
typically don't enjoy talking about
topics of X, Y, and Z. This subject
matter isn't for me. that subject isn't
for me. You find ways to if they're not
going to be taking the signs, be very
direct with them to say, I have a
boundary here. I'm not going to be
goated into this. I'm not going to be
led into this conversation. I'm not
going there. Now, we're at the part
that's one of my favorite parts, and
that is I'm going to answer a question
from a follower. If you're not already
part of my weekly newsletter, I send one
email once a week right to your inbox on
a communication tip. And those that are
on the newsletter can email me questions
and I'm able to answer it here on the
podcast. So, I have my my other phone
here and this one that I picked is from
Sammy. Sammy is in Florida. He says,
"Hey, Jefferson. Uh, love your tips. I
have an issue with work. There is a boss
that I have who always likes to talk
about whether it's gossip or politics,
whatever it is, he's always wanting my
input on it and I'd rather not give it.
It's not that I don't have an opinions.
I'm just not that much of a social
person and it makes me uncomfortable.
Love to hear your thoughts on this.
Sammy, I feel you, man.
So anytime, let me give you an example
of what's this making me think of in in
my mine my my old
my own world is
I'd have these conversations with my
grandfather. I'd go up every summer to
see him and it never failed. And this
happened definitely in the last five t
years or so where I started to come talk
to him and every time he turned the
conversation
to politics or some issue that I did not
want to talk about. It's not that he he
and I agreed on some things. We also
disagreed on some things, but that's all
he ever wanted to talk about. It just
kind of consumed his mindset. This is
what I'm going to encourage you to do,
Sammy. often the issue that you hear is
not the real issue. All right? It's not
the political issue that they want to
talk about or that um let's say maybe
he's oversharing or there's gossip or
something else. It's not that. It's an
underlying layer. Continue on with my
grandfather example.
My grandfather was the is the type that
you know he doesn't see a whole lot of
people dayto-day. And so whenever I'm
coming around and I'm giving him my full
attention, I might be the first person
he's really been able to talk to that
day and he wants to get out everything
that's on his mind. There's also that
element of he kind of wants to There's
people out there who want to feel
impressive with their knowledge
regardless of what side of the fence
anything is on. It doesn't mean it's
political, not political or religious or
any other controversial topic. They just
want to share that they're knowledgeable
about a given topic. So I I'm going to
encourage you to look behind the issue.
Why does he continue to come to you with
this? This boss or manager Sammy, why
does he continue to come to you with
this? Is it that he's just looking for
other conversation with you? Maybe it's
he just wants to have some kind of
interaction with somebody, especially if
it varies. If it's always the same issue
every single time, that's a little bit
different. But if he always comes to you
with something different, that might be
a suggestion that, well, he just wanted
to interact with somebody. Like we
talked about at the beginning of this
episode. Some people, it's not about
who's right, who's wrong. It's just the
competition. It's like, it's a hobby for
some people to find out, hey, can we
just kind of feel alive for a second if
we get up and angry about things even
though nothing in our world's going to
change. So when that happens and you
feel like you need to set some
boundaries in this discussion, I would
number one, I'd encourage you to
continue to indicate to him that you're
not going to give him any kind of fight.
You're not going to be on his side or
against his side. You're just going to
be disinterested. You're going to be
disinteresting by saying things like,
you know, I don't know. You know, I'm
not sure about that. Or, man, if I had
an opinion, I'd give one. Simple as
that. I don't know enough about it. or
it's, hey, I agree this is an issue.
Yeah, I agree. That's that's definitely
an issue. You're simply just
acknowledging something that they said.
Or if you need to be really really um
clear that this is not something you're
interested in and you don't like this,
it's okay to say, "I'd prefer not to
discuss this kind of stuff at work."
Simple as that. You have to do things
that sound authentic and genuine to you.
What you can't do is start to engage.
If you start to engage or you you begin
to just agree and be a yes man uh to
everything and go, "Yep, you're exactly
right. You're exactly right." Then he's
going to continue to come to you with
things. But if you continually show that
you're not going to be that much fun,
you're not going to be his person or you
just find that these aren't the kind of
topics that he's going to get with
somewhere. If you were able to say, you
know, I'd rather talk about you. That
was the key of how I kind of had to fix
my grandfather in our conversations. I
had to tell him anytime he got into this
rut, this continuous repeat of a hamster
wheel conversation, I'd say, you know,
I' I'd much rather hear about you.
That's it. I' I'd rather hear about how
you're doing. Nobody gets mad. Say me.
Nobody gets upset
if you want to move the conversation
about them. Nobody's like, "Oh, no. I
don't want to talk about that."
Everybody likes to talk about
themselves. So when you just kindly say,
genuinely say, "I'd rather hear about
you. How's everything going? We're good.
How's how's everything?" It shifts the
mindset and they're not going to be
like, "Oh, you you changed the topic."
Everybody likes talking about
themselves. Uh especially if it's
genuine, this this social connection
that you're creating. So that's the way
I'd handle that. Sammy, best of luck.
>> What about um the subject of small talk,
which we all I mean I think most people
hate small talk. Especially if you don't
like small talk, but
>> many people hate small talk. Is there is
there a skill at all to being a real
master of small talk in your view?
>> One would be don't ask questions that
elicit a one-word response. These are
what they call closedended questions.
You want these for cross-examination
because on cross-examination, I just
want yes or no questions. Did you go to
the store? Yes. No. I want you on open
when I'm on direct examination, I want
to open you up to discussion. I want you
to talk more. So, what you do is you
take advantage of asking questions that
open you up. Ask open-ended questions.
These are questions that begin with how
or what or when or where instead of uh
like did you go to the store? The same
effect would be did you have a good
weekend.
>> I'm only limiting you to a yes or a no.
>> You talk about these conversational
goals.
>> Yeah.
>> Having a conversational goal in your
small talk. You talk about that on page
I think 40 456 of of this book.
>> Yeah. So, as a conversational goal, I'm
a podcaster. I know I'm meeting you
today. So, I walk in here with a goal in
mind that when I start speaking to you,
I'm trying to get somewhere,
>> right?
>> Is that is that what you mean by
conversational goal?
>> Well, there's two separate sides. You
want to have a conversational goal
really for any conversation that you're
going to have. Now, that's different if
like you're in your hoodie and
sweatpants with your friend watching a
movie. Like, you don't have to have a
conversational goal. saying if you're on
oneonone with somebody at work, it's not
a bad idea if you go into their office,
you have a goal for where's the
conversation going to end because
otherwise it spins anxiety in the other
person. Like if somebody texts you and
says we need to talk period, you're like
I I automatically think it's the worst.
It's like, oh, something's terrible.
They we're we're uh we're breaking up.
Something's terrible. Something's on
fire. It's the worst because it's that
anxiety that that trigger of the
unknown. So instead, you always want to
have a conversational goal like the
frame we talked about. You're telling
them how you want the conversation to
end. Same kind of thing with small talk.
But when it's much easier when you set a
goal that's very low, like instead of
saying, "I want them to be so impressed
with me, they don't know what to do."
What's more impressive is when you're
curious about the other person. I want
to make sure that I ask at least three
questions of this person and see what
they have to say. That's a great goal. I
want to make sure that my goal is
understanding where they're coming from
just a little bit more. So with small
talk, people love to
tell them how they got there. People
love to talk about themselves. Everybody
knows that. One question to ask is how
they got to the present moment, for
example. How did you how did you learn
that?
>> Where did you come across this?
>> Yeah. How did you how did you get in
where you are today? And people are
like, "Oh, well, let me kind of talk
about myself for a minute." And people
love it because they get to tell a
story.
>> Very different if I just said, "Hey,
what'd you do this weekend?" "Oh, it was
good. We, you know, stayed home." That's
not there's no story element to that.
There's nothing you can do with that.
But if you get them to talk about a
story of what led them to their present
moment, much better. Another tip is you
get to talk to them about things that
are happening in the future rather than
looking at the past. The past is really
not that great for people because they
feel like it's boring. They don't feel
like the past is something is that
remarkable, but they typically find
things that they will look forward to in
the conversation. what are you looking
forward to doing this weekend? What are
you excited about? What's coming up for
you? They'll find things that go kind of
like, oh well, I'm kind of excited about
this, Y, and Z. But if you ask about
what's happened in the past, they kind
of have this like, ah, you know, I just
it's in the past. I didn't really do
anything. Now, we all know people that
no matter the conversation, they always
find a way to talk about themselves. And
even if it's not about themselves, it's
always seems to be their voice that
takes up the entire conversation. On
today's episode, we're discussing how to
handle people who dominate
conversations. When it comes to somebody
dominating a conversation, and not in
the good way, as in they're not letting
anybody else speak. They're the ones
always having to hear their own voice.
There's some things I need you to do.
Number one, interrupt them. You
interrupt that person. Now, I know it
doesn't sound like me to suggest that,
but it's true. Because if they're not
going to respect your time, then you
have to do it. And there's a particular
way I want you to do that. You interrupt
them by using their name. You start low
and then you go higher because people
listen to their name. Their name gets
their attention. It's the best word they
can ever hear is their name. So if I
were to hear you and I or somebody was
listening to me and I just said, "Hey,
Jefferson. Jefferson. Jefferson." You
say it as often and as loud as you need
to because it will eventually make them
stop. Number two, when they do stop, I
want you to filter and pass it. Here's
what I mean. Filter as in you're going
to summarize what they just said very
quickly and then pass it to somebody
else to say, "Hey, I totally hear you. I
understand what you've just saying. I'm
curious to hear what Bob has to say or
what Susie has to say or you turn it on
yourself. My thoughts are." And number
three, if they're still dominating the
conversation, then you got to put a time
limit on it. You have to find a way to
get out of there because you're not
reaching them. So, it's as easy as
saying, "Hey, I got about five more
minutes and then I need to get going. I
need to do other things." But time limit
is the only way to make sure that
they're just going to continue to talk
as long as they have an audience. And at
the end of it, you just have to
understand when somebody is dominating
the conversation, it's not a it's not a
two-way street. It's a one-way street.
It's a monologue. And you didn't buy a
ticket to hear it. So, if they're not
going to respect the way conversation
should happen, it's time that you
respect yourself. And most of the time
these kind of scenarios happen in
meetings,
zoom meeting, inerson meeting, it
doesn't matter. Where I see it most is
in zoom meetings because uh now after co
with everything a lot of the legal world
has moved to zoom where everything is
virtual and I'm sure that's the same way
in your world. But what typically
happens is that there is let's say a
dozen people, 10 people, eight people on
the Zoom and before you know it, it's
just one person talking the entire time.
It's one person who always has an
opinion. It's one person who always has
to feel like they're contributing to the
conversation way more than their share.
and they think truly inside themselves.
They just don't have the emotional
intelligence to realize that people
aren't really they're kind of getting
tired of you talking the entire time.
That filter isn't there for them. So,
they just they keep talking the entire
time. And in meetings especially, you
have to make sure that person doesn't do
that because it'll just kill your
meeting. It it'll it'll ruin it. It will
it will reduce productivity. It will get
people aggravated. You know that feeling
where all of a sudden they need to come
in again and everybody kind of lets out
a sigh like great this person again. Oh
geez, I wish we could just go it it'll
absolutely ruin your your meeting and
the productivity and where you want to
go. So when that kind of thing happens,
you have to step out in front of it the
first time. If you just let them drone
on because you're afraid to offend them,
you're afraid to um come out in front
and feel like that's being too direct,
then you just have to be okay with a bad
meeting because it's it's not going to
happen. Also, understand that when
people are dominating the conversation,
it's often a sense of insecurity. Like
most things, we feel that the more we
talk, the more intelligent we are. The
more people will see how smart we are,
how much we're trying to contribute. But
often what I find in meetings is the
person who speaks the most is typically
the one that knows the least. It's the
person who's the least out of touch. So
they have to overcompensate and feel
like everybody around them can have some
kind of faith in them. So they they talk
a whole lot. But often the more you say
it just shows the less that you know. So
you're going to be careful about that in
your next meeting. But here's the
takeaway. When somebody's dominating and
trying to control the conversation, you
have to step out in front of it quickly
because if you don't, it can it can go
south in a hurry. And I hear some of you
already going Jefferson, I don't I don't
feel comfortable interrupting this
person. I don't I don't feel comfortable
interrupting them. They're going to get
upset if I interrupt them. No, they're
not. They're going to want to stop and
listen. Maybe they might be a little bit
frustrated, but your purpose is true.
And here's how I'm going to help you
with that. When you need to interrupt
somebody, there's a difference between
me just starting to share my thought.
Let's say for example, you're talking to
me, telling me a story, and I've heard
this story a million times. There's a
difference between me cutting in and
going, "Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, we we
all know. We all know, okay?" And then
just ignoring you and continue to go on
with my thought. That's going to upset
you, right? That's going to make you
feel like, "Oh, they just they just
interrupted me. They just cut me off.
But if I were to use your name and say,
"Jefferson, I need to interrupt you."
All of a sudden, it doesn't feel like an
interruption because I told you what it
is. I told you that I'm interrupting
you. And I know we've discussed this
before on the podcast on how to handle
interruptions, but it's the same same
true for people who dominate
conversations. If I tell you that I'm
interrupting you, if I say I know I'm
interrupting or I need to interrupt you,
nobody takes offense to it because here
you're acknowledging what you're doing.
It's it's the acknowledgement of the
formality. So, yes, I understand.
Typically, I should not be interrupting.
I should be hearing you out. But in this
case, you have to because they're not
respecting the formality of I say
something, then you say something. I say
something, you say something. It's it's
just all about them. So if you took
think about it in a pie chart, there's
these people who control the
conversation to hear their own voice a
lot of ways. And they're totally fine
with taking up 98% of the pie and
leaving 2% to you. Really for that 2% to
tell them how great they are, how smart
they are. We're not going to be doing
that here. It's as simple as using their
name because it's going to get their
attention. They're going to perk up to
that to when you say, "Hey, Jefferson."
They're it's going to automatically turn
turn to you. They're going to look at
you, especially the more you raise your
voice in that way, but you're going to
do it kind. You're not going to do it in
a way that is rough or rude or just
exasperated. That's going to that's
going to make it go further south. Here,
you are pulling them back in in a way,
nudging them back in to how a
conversation is supposed to go,
especially one that you're going to be
involved in. Because understand what
you're doing here is also informing
them, hey, if you want to have a
conversation with me, this is how this
is going to go. I'm going to say
something, you're going to say
something, and we're going to
acknowledge these are the points. I'm
not here. I didn't buy a ticket to
listen to the show where I just sit and
you get to say everything, and I have to
be quiet. That's not it. Here, you are
showing them your manual. If if you want
to communicate with me, this is how
you're going to do it. So, when you use
their name, it gets their attention. And
it's easy way if you feel like you're
being too direct to tell them I need to
interrupt you. Mind this is a big key.
This is a big key point of this. Mind
you, do not apologize.
Look at me. Listen to me. Don't
apologize. Don't say I I'm so I'm so
sorry to interrupt you. You are not
sorry for it. You are not sorry for it
here. You need to do it. It is them that
has put you in this position. So, you're
not going to apologize for having a
boundary. You're not going to apologize
for needing to take a stance and say,
"This this can't continue." Cool. So,
you're not going to say, "I'm sorry." It
is, "I need to interrupt you." That is
as simple as that. Or, "I'm interrupting
you. I know I'm interrupting you." Both
of those will even allow them to go,
"I'm listening." It'll totally turn into
you and they're not going to take
offense to it because you're
acknowledging it in the moment. And one
point I want to make very clear is that
once you interrupt them and filter and
pass it part of that is the
acknowledgement. It is key that when you
need to take the conversation away from
somebody who is dominating and
monopolizing the conversation. You
acknowledge what they have said.
summarize it very briefly, even if just
one sentence because it it otherwise
they're going to feel totally shut down
and dismissed and it's going to lead to
negative things. I don't want that for
you. You can simply cure that by
summarizing what they just said. For
example, let's assume that
um you are talking to me on a given
topic and I interrupt you. Let's say
your name's Jefferson. Weird name. Such
a lame name. And I need to interrupt you
and I just go, "Hey, hey, Jefferson.
Jefferson." And then all of a sudden, I
just start cut off my thought and I go,
"Hey, hey, Jefferson. I I want to hear
what Lauren has to say about this. You
hear how all of a sudden I just felt you
you feel cut off from me? If I were to
say, "Hey, Jefferson, I want to Yeah, I
want to hear what Greg has to say."
You're going to feel cut off
immediately. Instead, if I said, "Hey,
Jefferson, I hear you. I I agree that
this point and that point and that
point, or I I hear you that this is
something that is frustrating you. I
don't disagree. I like to hear what so
and so has to say on this point here. I
just I summarize it. I say, "Thank you
for what you've shared." Again, I'm
distilling it to the important point.
And then I pass it to somebody else. Or
you can pass it to yourself easily. It's
just as simple as as say, "Hey,
Jefferson, I I hear your point. I I'm
not saying I agree with it. My thought
here is blah blah blah. I you're just
taking it because you've acknowledged
what they've said and then now you're
passing it on to the next one because
they're not sharing the ball, right?
They're they're hogging the ball the the
entire time. So, it's on you to kind of
kindly take it from their hands and pass
it on to continue playing the game.
Otherwise, nothing is going to happen. I
also want to make sure and add a
disclaimer in here that people who
monopolize conversations and dominate
them, it's not necessarily on purpose.
It goes back to what I originally said
is it's an insecurity. Bottom line, it's
an insecurity type thing that they don't
realize how much they're talking. I find
in my world that it is people who get
older in life that don't realize how
much they're talking. It is also the
plain sense of let's just let's let's
approach that situation that situation
with some grace and that you may be the
only person they've spoken to. you you
might be if it's somebody who's um older
and they haven't seen anybody today and
you're now the one that's going to be
talking to them, they might have a
week's worth of information of stories
and things that they just want to share
because in that moment they have a
reason for feeling like they're alive
and valuable and important and and
you're going to be the one to focus in
that. If that's the kind of situation,
then you just need to be patient. It's
that moment where instead of going, "Ah,
this is such a waste of time." Being
reflective is saying, "I need to slow
down a little bit. What what's here for
me?" So, understand there's always two
sides of the same coin. Especially for
even people that are neurode divergent,
they have ADHD,
maybe um they have other kinds of
um issues that make it difficult in the
way their brain functions to not stop
talking. And that's that's nothing that
does not mean that it's a weakness. It
just means it's something to learn and
to deal with uh and differently. And
that that's my whole point of this
episode is not that people who dominate
conversations are evil and terrible. It
is simply that it happens naturally with
everybody including yourself. And that
just means it's it's something to handle
and react to and respond to in a very
productive and efficient way. Here's a
hard truth. If you don't advocate for
yourself, nobody will. And if you don't
assert your needs, let's face it, you
will get walked over every single time.
At the end of today's episode, you're
not going to have to worry about it.
We're talking how to stand up for
yourself. The first thing to know about
standing up for yourself is knowing when
to do it. Because number one, not
everybody's worth getting out of your
chair for. It is a know your worth
mentality and we're going to talk
exactly where you need to go in your
mind leading up to these conversations.
Number two, get rid of the verbal
disclaimers. These are little statements
you say before you say what you need to
say. Like, hey, I'm I'm sorry, but I I I
just feel like maybe we're going to talk
about getting rid of those and how to do
it. Number three, stop justifying the
nos. Stop having to feel like you need
to explain yourself on and on just
because you turn somebody down. When you
do that, it takes away slowly from your
self-confidence. And I don't want to see
that. Now, maybe nobody's told you this,
but just because somebody has said
something does not mean that it requires
a response from you. Just because they
throw a pitch doesn't mean you have to
swing. You just let it go by. There's
this idea in our head that because
somebody gave us an opinion, we have to
give an opinion back. That's just not
true. When it comes to standing up for
yourself, it is often the person that is
not worth your time that you don't need
to give attention to. And often that's
the exact opposite of what we do. We
find ourselves trying to justify and
explain to people that do not matter in
our life. the people that that rank low
in our priority list, but yet we we feel
like we have to prove something to them
every single time that we talk.
Eliminate that concern. When people play
chess, it's expected that you're going
to take a pawn. Nobody freaks out about
it. Nobody loses their mind when
somebody takes a pawn because they know
the value is not the pawn. They can take
a rook, okay? They want to take a queen.
That's different. understand that
there's going to be lots of different
conflicts in your in your life, lots of
different conversations, they are not
all the same.
The the feeling you get by talking with
certain people, those friendships, where
they rank in relationship to you,
they're not all the same. So, what I
want you to understand is stop attending
every argument that you're invited to.
Just because that somebody gave an
opinion and said something to you, you
had the choice of just letting it go,
saying that does not require any
response from me, that is not worth my
time. That's why I say it's a know your
worth mentality. Before you stand up for
yourself and feel like you have to say
something, ask the question, is this
person worth getting out of my chair
for? Is this somebody that actually
needs part of my energy? because there
is a strength and a wisdom in conserving
your energy and protecting your peace.
So the next time that happens, I want
you to go through that filter and ask
yourself, is this person worth getting
out of my chair for? Because I I know my
worth. And please understand that goes
for anything that they say. Just because
they spew out garbage does not mean
we're in the business of picking up
trash. Let me say that again. Just
because they spew out garbage does not
mean that you're in the business of
picking up trash. You can politely tell
them where it should go and it's not
going to be on you. So understand that
part of protecting your peace is
understanding I know what they're saying
is not worth my time. I'm going to take
it and set it aside. Personally, what I
do in my my own life is I have a waste
basket. All right? I have a trash um bag
right next to me in my mind. And if
somebody says something I don't like,
rather than me feeling like I have to
throw it back to them and I have to pick
up that trash, that gross nasty thing
that they said and give it right back to
them, I just take it and I move it over
and put it in the trash. You can say
like at a computer or a laptop, you just
get it, you drag it over, and you put it
in in the recycling bin and then you
delete it. You don't have to worry about
it. You don't have to carry it. So
understand, just because they throw out
garbage at you does not mean that you're
in the business of picking up trash.
When you have to advocate for yourself,
part of that mindset is knowing how to
go into it. Too often there is the
hesitancy to say what you need to say.
We treat it like it's a I don't know
what do they have like the coal plunge
or a pool that's filled with cold water.
If you tiptoe into it, it's much worse
when you don't say what you need to say
right out of the gate and instead you
slowly walk into it with these little
disclaimers, what I call them. This
sounds like, hey, um, you know, I've
just been I I just feel like I need to
say this, I guess. It's maybe I'm
talking out of pocket here, but you ever
heard that? ever said that before where
you say, "Uh, yeah, I mean, listen, I'm
I'm sorry, but but maybe, you know, I
I'm just feeling more like you are
trying to hesitate saying what you need
to say, like you want to smooth it over.
You want to hedge to make sure nobody
feels like you're being too direct with
it. But when it comes to asserting
yourself, when it comes to stating your
needs, nobody's going to do it for you."
Remember, you're the one that has to be
bold and out in the open with it. So,
think of it as that cold swimming pool.
If you walk right into it, it's going to
not feel great. It's not going to look
smooth. It's not going to feel smooth.
You either have two choices. You don't
say it at all or you jump right in. When
you see people doing that cold plunge,
they don't walk right into it. They
don't slowly go into it. They put their
whole body into it. So, I want you to
get used to that idea of I'm going to
put my whole body into this thing. If I
have something to say, I'm going to say
it. I'm not going to feel like I have to
apologize for it. I'm not going to feel
like I have to be hesitant and hedged
the whole time. If it is something that
is on your heart, and it is something
that is truly asserting your needs in
your life, you have one chance, one
life, and this is it right here for you
to be able to state your peace, assert
your needs, and say what you need to
say. Now, another part of this is often
when it comes to standing up for
yourself, it happens in moments where
you need to say no to something. You
need to turn something down. Maybe
somebody's invited you to something. You
got offered something and you need to
say no, but you don't know how to say it
and you're just not sure. You can
advocate that you need to say no. Now,
we're going to talk later in this
podcast about how to say no to certain
things. How to decline something and
still be respectful. Uh how to disagree
and still be respectful about it in
those little bitty specific scenarios
here. This is the point I'm making of
that there are times when you have to
say something and they need to hear you
say no. And there's a difference between
saying no because after the end of it,
using that word because to justify it,
and just saying no. For example, let's
say you asked me a question and I just
said no.
enough versus no because you know I have
that thing that we talked about and you
know I I got to make sure that I take
care of this and it's just been really
busy lately and I just been so stressed
you know and so well I have that other
thing you know you see how it's much
weaker all of a sudden I I've added
three more sentences after the no and
I've slowly watered down the place that
I need to assert my needs. If I need to
say no to something I need to say no. So
eliminate that habit of always saying no
because it's just no. And if they need
to ask other questions, they're free to
ask other questions and you're free to
say no. Again, I want you to feel
empowered. All right. On this idea of
just because they asked me something
does not mean I have to give them
something. Just because they told me
something does not mean I have to have
an answer for something. Standing up for
yourself means that you are in complete
peace with who you are and your presence
in the conversation and you know your
worth wherever you are in that
conversation or if there should be a
conversation at all. So when you need to
say no to something, step into that.
Don't go with these little verbal
disclaimers. You say no to it. You don't
say because and add on a verbal um it's
like the opposite of a verbal
disclaimer. You add in everything
afterwards. No, because I'm just feeling
X, Y, and Z. You don't need that. The
word is no. Period. What lots of people
like to say and what I support is no is
a complete sentence.
>> How do you stand up for yourself in the
times where you know you should.
>> The biggest thing to know about standing
up for yourself is knowing when to do
it. There's a lot of people that you
if you always get out of your chair to
stand your ground on every little issue,
your legs are going to get tired. like
you just some people are worth getting
out of your chair for and some people
aren't.
>> There are some people that if you really
feel like an injustice like for me a
driving principle is justice. If I feel
like something is injust,
>> I'm much more um I guess it's unjust,
then I'm much more prone to get out of
my seat and say, "No, no, this is not
this isn't cool. That's not fair. This
isn't equal. You don't talk you don't
treat people that way." But if you if
you're the the yippy dog that always
barks at every car that goes by, it's
that same principle of really nobody's
going to nobody's going to listen nearly
as much. It's it's the walk quietly with
a a big stick kind of mentality. When
when you want to stand up for yourself,
it is this truth of knowing that
>> I I can I can choose to say nothing. And
a lot of times that is far more powerful
than anything I could say. if you're
going to say something ugly to me
and then I just let it hang.
Oh, it's one of the most powerful things
you can do is to look at them as if
>> there's nothing that you said that could
ever harm me and then they just don't do
it as much.
>> You're show you're telling them it's not
going to be fun for you if you go down
this road with me.
>> Interesting. Where did you learn that?
>> A lot of it is my upbringing. So I in
the book I talk about my I'm the oldest
of four.
>> I'm a fifth generation trial attorney.
So I've seen a lot of trials, heard a
lot of trials and I just had a weird
childhood where a good a wonderful
childhood where I get picked up from
school like get put in the corner of my
dad's deposition while he finishes or to
watch the end of a closing argument.
Then as the oldest of four had a lot of
experience just resolving conflict uh
plenty of conflict between brothers and
sisters and the oldest have my sister
and then my two younger brothers and
then a lot of it is um you'd think it
was law school but it's not. M
>> you have trials, but it's trial is
probably one of the most important ones
because it's let's say you're my witness
and let's say you're opposing you're
against me. You're adverse and I have to
cross-examine you. Meaning I have to
prove that you're wrong on something.
Now, as you already know,
>> there's another attorney who's going to
be ready to jump in and object to every
question I have. You have a judge that's
going to roll in the evidence of if my
question passes. you have a baiff court
reporter and then there's probably 12
people if we're in district court in the
state of Texas that are going to all be
listening to everything that I do. And
it's not so much the question I'm
asking, it's how I'm asking it.
>> So, I could be saying something and
let's say the other person objects,
judge rules against me. If I act like
I'm really upset about it, they're going
to think, "Oh, that's bad for his case."
If I if you say something and I act like
it really hurts me and I get mad like,
"Oh, that's not true,"
>> they're going to know, "Oh, this is
actually bad for his case." It's this
way of processing information with the
understanding that there are other
people in the room.
>> Even if you don't know it, even if
you're not
>> seeing it, there are other people that
are always paying attention to what
you're doing.
>> Wow. So, it's trial almost sounds like
it's like communication poker.
>> Oh, that's a good way of putting it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You have to play the
hands that you're dealt. So, let's put
it at that. Um, you know, I can't I
can't choose better facts. I can't
choose the law that I'm wanting to use.
>> And at the same way, it's not really
winning.
>> I mean, you might have a better hand
than me.
>> But it's just how I play it.
>> Yeah. And can I give it away or not?
>> Yeah.
>> Fascinating.
>> Well, and the thing is people think that
trial is this whole a gotcha game. It's
not. Everybody knows everybody's facts
before you go in.
>> None of it's a surprise.
>> None of it. Uh, every you I know all
your bad facts. You know all of my bad
facts. We all all know each other's
bruises as just who can who can play the
fiddle better. And uh it's it's a weird
situation in which when I ask you a
question, I'm also wanting the jury to
hear what you say and how that compares
with the facts that I have. So, a lot of
the tools that I teach about framing
conversations, it's the same way of how
I would frame a question or how I give a
big road map or how I would kind of make
you say what I want you to say or how I
have an open or closed-ended question.
It's all kind of the same principles.
>> Interesting. Do you use the principles
with your wife, too? No.
>> Does she call you? Does she call you
out?
>> She's also an attorney.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. We went to law school together.
Oh. Oh, my goodness. Yeah. And she knows
immediately if I'm trying, she'd say,
"Don't cross-examine me." like it's like
it's very very quick. She's very quick
to say that. And so, um, it's there's a
certain style of cross-examination where
if you start to just steam them out,
it's like, "Nope, you can't."
>> What would that sound like?
>> Use short little statements.
>> So, typically in TV, you see the wrong
stuff. TV is all so fake when it comes
to questions. Isn't it true whether or
you know, isn't true on or about
December 21st, 2024, you were at the
Bies in Bastrip, Texas? Yes or no?
You're never going to get that that kind
of answer from somebody. And you've seen
it like at the Johnny Depp trial. People
ask really bad questions.
Really, um, the best cross-examination
aren't questions. They're very short
statements.
>> And so maybe I'm wanting to draw out
that the car that you saw that weekend
was red.
And so I' I'd say something like, "You
were out that weekend?"
He'd say, "Yeah." Yeah. You see, I
haven't I didn't say yes or no.
>> I say, "You were out that weekend?"
Yeah. Saw a car.
>> Yeah.
>> Car car was red. And then sometimes they
go, "Well, you know, I don't know. I
really don't." And they start going on
and on and on. So the witness is trying
to run on you, trying to make you look
bad, and then all you do is just come
back
>> red. The car was red. Yeah. So it's
really easy to do that in, let's say, at
the kitchen table if you're like wanting
to make a a point, but that'll get you
in trouble.
>> Yeah. If your wife's an attorney.
>> Mhm. Yeah. Yeah. She doesn't She doesn't
allow any of that. She c she catches
that real quick.
>> Yeah. My husband does the opposite. He
does the CIA method, which is often
saying things like, um, oh, um, like
I'll be like, "Hey, you know, did you do
X, Y, and Z?" And he'll be like, "X, Y,
and Z." And then I'll be like, "Yeah,
you know, did when I said that we were
going to do this." And eventually he'll
just keep asking the question back like,
"Oh, did I do that?" And finally I'll
I'll either just get annoyed and walk
away because I don't think he's
understanding me. And it works
beautifully like the mirroring.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And except now that I'm
on to it, he got me for years with that.
>> Years.
>> Yeah. I think I was a slow on the
uptick. I was like, never mind.
>> That's funny.
>> I just I'm just not gonna get engaged.
>> If I were trying to earn your respect
throughout this conversation, if I were
to want to come across as somebody that
I know what I'm talking about, if I was
somebody that wants to come across as
being high value, what do you think's
the biggest thing that I should focus on
for me to portray that to you?
>> It's a feeling. And that feeling is
warmth. If you really want to portray
confidence, there's the temptation to
feel like you have to be big. You need
to be right in their face. Hey, high
energy, high impact all the time. That
does not convey confidence right away.
It conveys
desperation. It might convey eagerness.
It might convey too much. So, where
somebody's just you're you're sitting
with me uh or with anybody and you come
on super strong, that might throw off
the the equilibrium of the conversation
where it's going, "Oh, this is this is
this is too much. I'm just getting to to
know you." So, it's much more easier if
you think about the feeling of warmth
and what that is and how that sounds and
how that resonates with you. So if I
want to portray confidence,
uh it's to slow down my words, to make
sure that I don't uptalk with things.
It's to make sure that I am pausing
correctly with you and making eye
contact and having that intention. I'm
not looking around the room. I I'm
focused right with you. My chin's up.
I'm not looking down. My shoulders are
back. and I'm just wanting to engage
fully with who you are and who I am and
making sure that we match the same
frequency rather than coming in hot and
heavy.
>> Why do you think people come on too
strong in conversation?
>> A desire to be loved, a desire to be
liked, a desire to feel like they are
special and they're different from
somebody else. It's it's just
overcompensating most of the time. If
somebody is you're wanting to project
high energy, it's different if you're
performing in front of a whole bunch of
people. you're speaking to a bigger
audience. Got it. You need to have that
energy because it has to be spread over
a lot much bigger number of people. But
if it's just one person, you you don't
need to come on that strong. It's much
easier just to meet them where they are.
In other words, I don't have to I I
don't have to come parachute into the
conversation. I just need to walk up and
shake your hand. And they need to feel
that in your voice and your tone and
your tenor and how that operates.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I've noticed with
myself that the lower my self-esteem was
at the time, the more I needed to fake
it in a conversation and try to show up
in a way that wasn't who I was because I
was so miserable with with the person
that I was. I felt that the other person
would automatically know that there was
something wrong with me um because of
the way that I was feeling. And then
what I realized is, you know, most
people aren't really paying attention to
that. you actually look more unconfident
when you're trying to, you know, fake it
to somebody throughout the course of a
conversation. Like I'm wondering,
I know for me it helped me a lot to work
on myself through other mechanisms,
fitness, my relationship to myself, my
personal relationships, purpose, and so
on. That that allowed me to be able to,
I think, sit here and be able to have
these conversations like this. Do you
think that for you personally is that
the way to appear more high value, you
know, high level of self-respect, etc.
Or is it just exposure therapy through
practice, through having conversations
like this? It's a comfort with yourself.
It it exposure helps just by repetition.
You can only know so much. It has to
have application, but it comes from
within. I see this a lot of time in a at
a jury trial. So, as a litigator, I go
to court and often I will have a witness
or I'm cross-examining a witness who is
trying to be somebody they think the
jurors in the jury want them to be. They
want need to portray some maybe they
need to portray sympathy, hoping to
gather sympathy from the jury. But
people have a six sense about them. We
can just tell. There's no way to really
put words to it, but it's very easy to
go, that person is not being true to who
they are. Something is off. Something is
I can't describe it, but I can just feel
it. I can hear it. You know it when you
see it. And so there's that temptation
to be something different than who you
are, but that typically draws away. It
doesn't it rarely if ever gives you the
outcome that you want. Authenticity is
being exactly who you are on the inside
as you are on the outside. people. It's
leave the window fronts for for
shopping, but don't don't make it your
home base of who you are and your
personality because eventually it's
going to either hurt the relationship
that you're trying to have which is
based upon a a falsity or it's going to
eventually grind you down because after
a while it's just going to be friction
and and that's going to have a rub and
that's going to get worn and and that's
going to be hard to you're going to have
that identity crisis further down the
road. much better to to be who you are
now.
>> Yeah. We often have that problem with
overcorrection, right? Where if we're
feeling a lack of self-esteem, we want
to overcorrect it by trying to portray
that we have a higher level of
self-esteem than we actually do. And
people can pick up on that right away.
But I will say I think on the the
opposite end of that, like I can tell a
lot by somebody when they shake my hand.
If they have a weak handshake, I can
just tell like they're struggling. They
got something going on. They have a low
level of self-esteem. Maybe this is me
overgeneralizing, but but for the most
part, that's just maybe my perception
and my bias and people who walk with and
looking, you know, at the ground when
they're walking because I did all of
that and I wasn't very confident. So, do
you think in situations like that where
people are feeling
less confident, passive, they're maybe
not an extrovert, but they're trying to
appear confident. How, like, in your
experience, like what's the best way for
somebody to bridge that gap so that
they're not turning somebody off by
being too passive, having a weak
handshake, looking down, but they're
also not coming out as this
overcarismatic person, which can be easy
for people to pick up on right away.
>> It's a it's a balance. And that balance
is specific to context. It's specific to
the situation and a lot of different
factors. There's this fear and it's it's
a it's a type of psychological threat of
identity and that makes you question
what if they don't like me? What if they
don't like who I am? Is who I am enough
in this moment? And that causes you to
have maybe not the weak handshake, but
it causes you to to feel down to have
that negative energy. Whereas on the
opposite end, if you're always
always needing to be the person to say
something, often the person who says the
most knows the least. You you've been in
those boardroom meetings and the person
who's always chiming in is typically the
person who's least connected with what's
going on. But the confident person, the
authentic person knows that they don't
have anything to prove. So the advice is
understand you have nothing to prove.
Your value is exactly what your value
is. You don't dilute it by saying too
much. You don't undervalue it by not
saying enough. So it's this this
understanding of I don't have anything
to prove, not with my words, not with my
actions. I know exactly who I am. And
that allows you to
be able to use pauses more effectively.
It allows you to have stronger
conversations because less is often more
when your words are more concentrated.
When you say less, confident people know
they don't have to have an answer to
everything. They don't have to say every
little thing that comes to their mind.
The person who's the most knowledgeable
in the room, typically in that board
meeting, is the one who says the least.
And so it's it's it's always the the
reverse of what we what we originally
think.
>> What are some things that we can say um
or even some actions that we can do to
make people trust us more and and maybe
improve our credibility? This could be
um how maybe what how you do as a lawyer
in a professional setting or maybe even
like in a personal setting. How do we
get people to to trust us more?
>> That's a hard question. I I would say
to want to be trusted more, you have to
create a safe space for people to come
into. Like when you think about walking
into a home, you can tell or a room, you
can tell pretty quickly. If you walk
into a room and feel, "Okay, I'm I'm
safe." You walk into a friend's house,
you feel more comfortable. You walk into
a stranger's house, you're much more
stiff and rigid. You're just not as
comfortable in their space because you
don't know if it's safe yet. And I use
safe in a way to say you don't feel like
you can relax. You have all your systems
kind of watching out for anything. Um,
what I like to do to create that safe
space
is to acknowledge that they came to me
and that they're talking to me and that
I show positivity in that. For example,
with kids, all right, you you especially
when they get older in years, you want
them to feel like they can trust you
with anything, right? That they they're
going to they're not going to hide stuff
from you. They're not going to go to
somebody else to share things with. You
want to be their person same it maybe
not just kids maybe it's co-workers
maybe it's a uh your employees whatever
it is you want to feel like you're a
safe place
first step in that is to
make them feel like their presence is
invited that that you feel like I I just
you're you're saying I acknowledge that
you had choices with who you shared this
information with. I'm glad that you came
to me. So an easy way to say that is I'm
glad that you came to me with this. I'm
glad you're talking to me about this. So
it's I'm glad you are talking to me.
Just that period alone is going to show
okay confirm in their mind. What means
more? You come to me with bad news and
all of a sudden I just flip out. I I'm I
start yelling at you. How could you?
What are you talking about? You did
this. That's not going to create trust
because that doesn't create a safe
space, right? much rather to start with
a big
I'm really glad you came with to me with
this and now now you feel safe now you
feel a lot more at ease um thank you for
telling me glad I'm glad you came to me
thank you for telling me and then when
they get to share that with you instead
of trying to correct them it's
appreciating their perspective then then
get to share what your advice is or what
you're feeling but if you really want to
create trust you have of indicate to
them that they are okay and they are
safe.
>> Something another example of this that
I've heard you mention is it's like you
had a case once where someone was like
um trashtalking all lawyers and they
were kind of bringing you into the mix
and your response was you know what
maybe you're right. And I feel like that
that statement itself builds trust too,
right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah, definitely. Um
because I'm not disagreeing with them
and they're hearing the the the word
right. So there's a there's concepts of
in psychology I know of being flexible.
So if you're being too loose in the way
you think, you open the door for chaos.
If you're really close-minded, you keep
everything really tight. Well, then you
can't really let anybody in and you
can't let anybody out. So if you stay
flexible in this kind of well maybe so
mindset of we'll see mindset. We'll see.
Maybe you're right, maybe I'm wrong. Who
knows? You keep that kind of mindset.
You're staying flexible. And in that
particular position, when they're
saying, you know, attorneys are the
worst thing ever. All right. Well, I
could choose to get defensive or I can
choose to be flexible. And I say, well,
maybe you're right. And what are they
going to say? I mean, it it it totally
like defangs the whole situation. I've
I've shown some humility of saying,
well, it's maybe you're maybe there's
some truth to that. And there is in any
profession in any you always consider
the possibility that I could be wrong at
any given point. Um and to say that
they're just used for them to hear the
word right is going to calm them
immediately versus I could say you're
wrong. You're so wrong. They're just
going to prickle. They're going to
bristle right there. I don't lose
anything at all by saying well yeah
maybe you're right. What would you say?
Why is it so important that people get
communication right? Like what do you
think impact it will have on people's
lives? Like for the people that are
listening, why should they care so much
about their communication?
>> Communication is the thing that connects
everything that's has happened and will
happen. It's impossible not to
communicate unless you're not alive.
>> If there's communication, that's one
thing. But when you don't communicate,
even when there's silence, you're still
communicating something. If I don't
respond to your text in 5 minutes, that
says something. If I don't respond to
your text in 5 days,
>> it means you don't like me at all.
>> It says it says something else.
>> True. That's true.
>> And so like in a silence, in a pause, it
might be the absence of words, but it's
not the absence of communication.
Everything that's led you to this point
has happened from your your words. In in
many ways it is very true that what you
say is who you are Christa. I mean it's
just it's just what it is. It's for the
vast majority of your life people will
only experience you based on what comes
out of your mouth. What you say like if
somebody says something and you just
meet them for the first time and they
leave right away you're going to go I
like that person. What you meant is
>> they said nice things.
>> Or if you don't like somebody's attitude
and they're rude you're not going to
like that person. So it's really the
power of your words or even go with
conflict
>> like how you led to who you found now
most likely if you had exboyfriend
ex-husband or whatever there was a
conflict
>> and how that conflict was handled led to
the next event. How you left that job
because there was a conflict and you got
>> let go or you left led you to the next
thing.
>> So it's communication is um
>> in everything that you do. Mhm. With
relationships, if we were to speak on
that, what I found in my relationships
is like, yeah, it's so interesting you
said it was so much the unsaid because
it was so much more unsaid than said.
And it was crazy to witness cuz I think
my parents would do this, too. My
parents got divorced. They did their
best, but it's like they would be having
whole dialogues in their heads that
would not be verbalized into words. Oh,
>> yeah.
>> Or communicated into words. What's
happening there when people even with
their bosses or friends where it's just
the mind is really going and the mind
has a lot to say but they're unable to
bring it to words.
>> Well, a lot of the problem is they're
waiting till they're talking to figure
out what they want to say.
>> So, they haven't done the work ahead of
time. All they've done is just expected
to go how it's gone in their head,
>> how they he said it in the shower, how
they said it. I mean, they make great
points when they're driving in their
car, but when it comes to meeting that
person face to face, they can't they
can't do anything because they haven't
they haven't laid that groundwork.
>> Or let's say you and I come home after a
long day.
>> You've been thinking about something you
need to talk to me about and you've been
thinking about it for eight hours. Eight
hours you've been stewing on it,
>> clocked into my job, started thinking,
>> you know everything about what you want
to talk about. Meanwhile, I get home and
you're like, "Hey, can I talk to you for
a second?" Uh, and then you just dump
eight hours worth of thought and emotion
that's important to you.
>> I'm catching a cold.
>> Yeah. I'm not ready. Where do you Where
does this coming from? And all of a
sudden, you expect me to carry the same
importance and weight to it as you have
for the last eight hours when I'm I'm
not ready for this. And so you you have
a 100% of a subject you want to talk
about when I have 20% of the bandwidth.
It's just gonna it's going to go south
every time.
>> How would you as a couple then? So
because that's a situation that happens
with people. What would you say?
>> So let's talk about for her.
>> Yeah.
>> You know if if you are stewing all day,
what's the strategy that she can take
and what is the strategy that the man if
we're saying this is a man can take in
that situation?
>> Yeah. One, you want always want to make
sure you have dedicated time for the
important conversations. I'm not talking
about like just, hey, how was your day?
It was good. The little bitty things,
that's that's fine.
>> The big major conversations need to have
uninterrupted dedicated time that you
have set aside for it. Even if that
person, you have five minutes to talk
about it in that time frame, it's still
better to push it off for another five
minutes just so you both can ready
yourself for what you're going to talk
about. Hey, when when you get about 10
minutes here in a little bit, just let
me know. It's much better to prepare
them. So, if you're the let's say from
the woman's standpoint, uh in our
scenario,
>> you want to use a frame. And how I teach
frames is that you tell them what you
want to talk about, how you want to feel
after
>> the conversation is over. And that's the
big part, telling them how you want to
feel after the conversation. And three,
you get their buy into it. And it sounds
like this. Let's say uh we get home and
you've already texted me in the day.
Hey, I can we spend 10 minutes for a
conversation that I want to talk about
later. Perfect. So, we're in that time.
You're going to start with, hey,
Jefferson, I'd like to talk with you
about something you said last name, so
that means trouble.
>> Yeah. Well, you know what I mean. Let's
just say, "Hey, babe. Hey, babe. Hey,
babe. Bae." Whatever it is. Uh, hey,
love. And I like to talk with you about,
you know, what what happened last night.
And I I want to walk away with the
conversation. I want to walk away from
the conversation or I want to walk away
with I I want to end the conversation
feeling like X, Y, and Z. So it could be
as simple as even I'm not asking you to
fix anything. I just need you to hear me
out. Or I just want to say this. I just
need to feel understood. I don't need
you to do anything with it. Now telling
me that ahead of time, super helpful.
Otherwise, I'm looking how to fix it the
entire time.
>> Totally.
>> Then the the third step is you're just
getting their buy in. And that's sounds
as simple as that sounds good. Can we do
that? Is that Are you willing to do
that? And now
>> a yes before you start.
>> Yeah. Because now it's like I've signed
an invisible contract. Now I'm in it
with you and I don't want to break my
work because I've agreed to it. The key
is for both people, you stay within that
subject. If you don't, if you break out
of that
>> and you you go, you know what, actually,
and you want to bring up
>> five other different things, well, now
you've busted out of your frame. Now
you've
>> now everything get cut loose. Instead,
you want to try and dial in just on that
one issue. For the guy's perspective,
one big part of it is conversations go
south when somebody forces you to have a
conversation you're not ready for.
>> So, if I need to say, I can tell I'm not
ready for this. I do want to talk about
this. I can tell right now I'm not ready
for a good conversation. I'm not ready
for this conversation. I want to talk
about it.
>> I I Let me Can we do it after dinner?
Give me Give me some time. I've
>> You need You You have to communicate
that you're not ready.
>> Cuz when people say, "Hey, you have 5
minutes." What they really mean is,
"Hey, do you have about 45 minutes for
me to tell you a story that could really
waste your time?" Means nothing.
>> Like if somebody says, "Hey, you got a
second?" It depends. Like it's like, "Do
you have a second to what? Tell me you
like my shoes or or Yeah. Are you about
to just come in and and wreck my entire
day? Uh, like that's Can you just let me
know? Can we put
>> Yeah, honestly, let's do the scale.
>> Yeah, I'm going to send you this
feedback form. So, you can go ahead and
let me know how how that's going to go.
>> I really like the um I really like that
frame for women to think about,
especially with men
>> because a lot of men are going to be
what can I fix? What can I do?
>> So, expressing the feeling that you're
wanting to have and I also think it's
helpful because it gives women the
clarity to really think about it. It's
like, okay, how do I want to feel? Cuz I
think if you're in the reactive mode of
frustration or anger, you could be like,
I want to feel
>> Yeah. You want to get after
>> I want Yeah. I want to
>> I want to square up.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I want to punch you in the face. So it's
like, okay, how can I regulate in my
system like coming out of the fight or
flight and I think this is a lot of
>> I want to talk about that too, like the
relationship to the body.
>> Yes.
>> Because so much of it is you getting
triggered and then you losing the plot
or losing, you know what I mean? like
this this where it's like cuz I was even
thinking for a lot of
>> previous relationships I was in if I was
like hey do you have like 10 minutes
>> it would be like terrifying
>> and it was probably me creating the
situation that made the terror but like
I I think a lot of people get really
nervous with like the request for time
because they think they're in trouble.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you find that?
>> Oh yeah. It's let me tell you why that
happens. All right. because it is
it is telling them that there is
something to fear that is unknown. One
of the biggest tri triggers is the fear
of the unknown.
>> Now, let's say you and I are working and
I text you.
>> I need to talk to you. Period. Or worse,
we need to talk.
>> Period. You're going to think you want
to call me immediately. What What
happened? What's going on? Oh my gosh.
Something I mean it is or oh my it's
over. He he hates me. Everything's gone.
I've done something wrong.
>> It's all fear. fear, fear, fear, fear,
fear, and that anxiety takes over.
>> That's what happens. And that's why
you're saying it's it feels terrifying
for that other person because constantly
we're looking to see that fight or
flight. Is there a bear in the bush?
Like, what's going to come out to get
me?
>> So, our body is already doing that. What
I talk about in my book is like these
three main pillars of say it with
control, say with confidence, say it to
connect. And part of saying it with
control
>> is what you just lined out is with your
body. So our body is very much tied to
how we communicate.
>> When you hear somebody yell,
>> what they're trying to do is scare you
away.
>> It's the fight or flight. When somebody
says a hurtful word or word that it's
cutting, it's because they're trying to
physically make you go away. That it's a
threat. Maybe you said something that
undermined me and my body goes, "Hey,
Jefferson, I don't Hey, so I didn't like
that, that tone that I heard." Yeah.
>> Hey, so I didn't like that. Uh, and all
of a sudden, I'm going to get defensive
because my body saying, "I don't like
this threat. I feel triggered by this."
>> Yeah.
>> And there's lots of different ways to
feel triggered.
>> Knowing your triggers are is very
important.
>> That's a good one. But when that
happens, your body naturally goes into
it. Like right that that moment between
a conversation and an argument like when
there's just enough friction that it
starts to ignite
>> and things rub you the wrong way. It uh
it kind of just takes it takes over.
That's why your your pupils will dilate.
So you're focused in your nostrils will
flare to like get you more oxygen. You
feel ner like you shake.
>> Yeah. you you get tense cuz your body's
just physically ready to go. Or on the
like fight or flight,
>> you're wanting to hang up the phone. You
want to leave the room.
>> You want to get out of here. Who Who How
many times have you said, "I can't do
this.
>> I'm not going to do this right now." And
you're ready and you're ready to go. It
is your fight or flight saying, "Get out
of there."
>> Yeah.
>> And that's it's Yeah. Exactly. And it's
just ti It's
>> Yeah.
>> Your communication is tied to how your
body feels. And so you have to there are
steps that you can use to regulate
yourself so that does not happen.
>> Yeah. I realized how detrimental that
was in past relationships was my I'm
done.
>> I'm so done.
>> Yeah. I'm done.
>> I can't.
>> We're done.
>> Yeah.
>> It's like after
>> I literally cannot
>> after 10 years of that. It's like
I don't believe you
>> anymore. Um something I want to just
talk about and then I want to talk more
about the control. All right, those the
three
>> was related to the first part where we
were talking about that conversation
between like a man and woman. Say she
has something she wants to talk about
preparing him to get home. I think
something that's so important that you
mentioned that I think is
>> a game changer for relationships. And so
I think women need to pay attention to
do is not um loading everything on. So
it's like we're going to talk about one
thing.
>> Oh yeah.
>> And and you have to only talk about one
thing. You can't, this is me talking to
my previous self. You can't be like,
"Okay, and then this is feels good and
then I'm going to talk about this thing
and this thing and this thing." Like
focusing on the one thing is such an
important aspect of communication in
relationships.
>> Yes. Um I like to say if you're talking
about everything, you're talking about
nothing.
>> So true.
>> And but even in a business context, you
you have that meeting and your boss
says, "All right, everybody, we got a
lot to talk about." And you already know
right away you're rolling your eyes
going, "This could have been an email."
they have when you're talking about too
many things, nobody feels like it was a
good productive meeting. Same thing in
the intimate conversation when you're
just lobbing issue after issue after
issue, it's uh especially on the other
person, it's one, it wears them down.
Two, they're not going to retain
any of it. It's just it's much better to
go very deep on one singular issue. The
most important thing on that frame is
telling them how you want to feel or how
you want to walk away. if it's I want to
walk away with this conversation with us
having alignment or being on the same
page or just you hearing me out not
needing to fix it. Any way that you can
give them a heads up of how you want to
end because so many times we get in that
conversation and you're going at least
from let's say in this scenario the
guy's perspective what do you want?
What's your point?
>> And so what do I say? I start to jump in
and go oh so you want me to do this? You
go no no no no that's not that's not it.
Okay. So I'm still listening. And then
later on I go, "Oh, so you want me to do
this?" And you go, "No, no, no. You're
not hearing me." I'm like, "I'm
listening." And you go, "It's because at
that point in time, you you truly don't
know how to land the plane." Totally.
>> You just you don't know.
>> So
>> sometimes it's like if you have as a
woman, you like have been in it all day
and then you finally have an audience.
It's like you don't want it to go away.
You're just like,
>> "I just need you to sit."
>> Yeah. And Yeah. Yeah.
>> You're like, "I'll just keep the
microphones running, please."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I just need you to
just need you to sit.
>> Yeah. Actually, now that I see you're
attuning to me, I just want to rip.
>> Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh but that's
that's what happens because you you're
trying to you just get in and you wait
until you're talking to figure out what
you want to say. And I what you'll hear
is the person go, "No, no, no. That
that's uh no, no, wait, wait, wait." And
they start continue to talk more and
you're just thinking, "What's what's
your point? What do you need from me?"
And now now you're going, "Oh, you don't
even care." Like you you weren't even
listening to me and you're like, "What
are you talking What are the three power
moves in conversations
that
really set you up for success in any
conversation?
>> Number one is silence, just nothing. So
if somebody were to say something that's
snarky,
the best move is to say nothing. You
just kind of sit back and you look
around and you look up, you look off.
I'm telling you, nine times out of 10,
they can't take it.
>> Really,
>> they can't take that silence because
then
then it's spread out. You've just
exposed instead of you covering it up
with something else that says, "Excuse
me, did what did you say?" You're just
leaving it open. Kind of like that which
that the best foot you're going to put
out right now that one.
>> You go that the one we're going to
choose. And if you just let that silence
sit there often times, and you probably
heard this, they go, I shouldn't have
said that. You you got to give them that
chance.
>> That's number one.
>> Yeah. Number one is you got you got to
give him a chance of of that silence.
Number two, acknowledge that it could be
without acknowledging that it is. And
you say of saying, "Well, maybe so.
Maybe you're right."
>> And not say you're right.
>> No,
>> but maybe you are.
>> Maybe maybe you're right. But it's that
piece of humility that says, "Yeah,
well, maybe you're right." I had a guy
once who said, uh, I was deposing him
and, you know, all these all you
lawyers, worst things that ever happened
to America kind of talk. And I said,
"Well, maybe you're right, but today
it's just going to be a conversation
between us.
>> Is it okay if you're just talking to
Jefferson?" And he said, "Yeah, I can do
that."
>> Wow. And so it's that ability to just oh
maybe so but I could have I could have
gotten really defensive with him. I
could have I could have chosen to taken
that personally instead just dropped it.
Uh the other power other power move is
to hold off on the timing.
So when you are mad that's generally not
the best time to do it. when like when
when you know you've done something
wrong, you want somebody to be mad at
you to like fight me, please. Like, I
know I've done something wrong. I Let's
Let's have this out. We'll talk about
this. You You want to talk about this at
noon?
>> Let's talk about
>> Let's put it in the calendar for
tomorrow.
>> You got it. Let's Oh. Oh, well, I'm
okay. It's
>> Well, I'm I'm glad I'm glad you said
that. Well, then, you know, I don't
really have my thoughts together on
that, but
why don't we car to talk about that at
noon tomorrow? What do you think? Now,
they're like, "Oh my god, like I just I
just said something that
>> I shouldn't have said."
>> But that's that's a much better way of
of uh of handling it because at that
point, you have not lost any confidence.
You have not lost your credibility.
>> You just you've maintained that you're
the one in control at all times. And I'm
telling you, the key is just starting
with your breath
>> and choosing to be quiet,
>> right?
>> If you were if you were to say something
to me and I responded right away, like
if you were to say, um, I don't know, do
you do you, um, do you enjoy matcha tea?
I go, no. Versus me thinking,
>> no.
>> Like there's just a different
connotation to it when you think about
it.
>> Yeah. Um about 14 years ago,
um
someone gave me a a line that became one
of the most powerful uses of language
over the last 14 years to help me get
almost anything I want or more of what I
already have.
And I use it all the time. When I go
uh order a coffee, I use it. When I go
to a hotel and try to get an upgrade, I
use it. When I'm working with uh
partners and collaborators, I use it.
And the line is, what's the chance?
What's the chance you give me a discount
on this? What's the chance you can give
me an upgrade in this hotel room?
>> What's the chance you can give me in
first class?
>> Yeah. What's the chance we can
collaborate in a bigger way?
>> Yeah.
>> What's the chance you can go a little
more on this?
>> And
I've used that over and over again
because it continues to work. And I
almost use it as a game daily. Like
>> any store I go into, I'm just like,
>> what's the chance you got 10% off on
this?
>> Yeah.
>> Just to see if you can make something
happen.
>> Cuz if you don't ask, you're not going
to get it.
>> Right.
>> And um it's just like a way to be
playful. It's a way to like see can I
enroll someone in something that I maybe
I shouldn't be getting but I would get.
>> Yes.
>> And it often works where the unexpected
happens. Is there another
line of communication that you use maybe
even unknowingly that you use
consistently that seems to
>> just help you enroll people in more of
what you want?
So I do I absolutely use the what's the
chance really?
>> Yeah. So I I will use that when it feels
like a surface like a stalemate between
the other attorney
>> and look what's the chance that your
client's going to be able to do
>> X Y and Z.
>> Also I will try to separate the attorney
from the client. same way I do with like
the reception clerk versus the hotel. I
I I make sure that I acknowledge them as
the person because I acknowledge their
struggle of what they're going through,
>> right?
>> And so if I talk to the attorney of
look, I can only imagine, you know, all
the updates you're you're having to do
or all the work you're putting through.
I I know that this is how you're doing
the best thing you can for your client.
I mean, between me and you, what what
what's the chance that we can do X, Y,
and Z? or if I were to do or if I were
to say or if my client were if I were to
encourage my client to do this,
is that something that I should do?
And it gives them something to think
about,
>> right?
>> The same way like at a let's say at a
hotel or something like that. I I can
only imagine you just been how how
long's your shift?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. 7 hours. Oh my gosh. Yeah. That's
going to be And so you just Yeah. you
kind of create that connection with them
that says I'm talking to you
individually as a person rather than
seeing you as the whole then because
that's who they are.
>> Yeah, exactly. That's powerful. If you
enjoyed that clip and want to see the
rest of the conversation, you can click
right here.